[Música]
hoy vengo a hablarles otra vez de
energía es muy posible que muchos de
nosotros hayamos escuchado con mucho
orgullo hablar sobre la energía limpia
de costa rica es una frase que se
divulga y se repite y se comunica en
muchos medios nacionales y medios
extranjeros hoy quiero darles un pequeño
secreto la energía de costa rica no es
limpia lo explico todos los días
nosotros utilizamos mucha energía en
nuestras casas en nuestras industrias y
comercios y sobre todo para
transportarnos parte de esa energía
proviene de la electricidad y aquí si la
energía de costa rica- la electricidad
de costa rica es prácticamente 100%
limpia lo cual es un gran logro y es un
motivo de gran orgullo otra parte de
nuestra energía proviene de las biomasas
las cuales utilizamos principalmente
para el procesamiento de la caña de
azúcar o del café o incluso en las
cocinas de leña
y una buena parte de la energía proviene
del petróleo y sus derivados los cuales
participan en todos los sectores de
nuestra economía el detalle está en que
la electricidad que es completamente
limpia y renovable es apenas un 20% de
la energía de costa rica que consumimos
las biomasas que podríamos llamar
carbono neutrales son aproximadamente un
15% y el petróleo que está en todos los
sectores de la economía representa el
restante 65% lo cual es positivo carbono
positivo ahora esto no debería ser
realmente un gran problema si el
petróleo en realidad tiene muchas
ventajas es una de las maneras más
eficientes que conocemos el día de hoy
para almacenar energía en poco peso en
poco volumen es transportable
normalmente el líquido gaseoso lo
podemos bombear es práctico lo podemos
llevar de un lado al otro tenemos bueno
algunos tienen una industria con más de
100 años de experiencia extrayendo lo
distribuyendo por todo el mundo y
comercializando lo para mover la
economía y existe lo que podríamos
llamar
la aplicación estrella el motor de
combustión interna una máquina que por
cientos de años nos ha ayudado a desde
cortar el sácate movernos mover barcos y
aviones y sin embargo en las últimas
décadas por las buenas y por las malas
nos hemos dado cuenta de que el consumo
del petróleo conlleva serios problemas
en costa rica nos hace energéticamente
dependientes
nosotros no tenemos reservas de petróleo
o de gas natural y si las tuviéramos
mucho se opondrían por motivos
ambientales sociales y económicos
también el aire que estamos respirando
hoy aquí en este momento no cumple con
los estándares mínimos de la
organización mundial de la salud y esto
le cuesta a nuestro país en el orden de
100 millones de dólares al año en la
atención de males respiratorios y para
terminar estamos afectando el clima del
planeta a nivel a nivel planetario e
incluso acabo de aprender
'estamos acidificando el agua de los
océanos y esto está comprometiendo la
vida de las generaciones que vienen
detrás de nosotros
el problema del consumo de petróleo pero
es relacionado con las emisiones de
carbono cuando usamos el petróleo y los
combustibles fósiles para extraer su
energía y los quemamos se producen
emisiones como el dióxido de carbono el
monóxido de carbono ln o equis y éstas
son responsables de los efectos
negativos que acabamos de hablar hace
poco por eso el reto es descarbonizar la
economía es decir seguir usando la
energía que necesitamos pero sin los
efectos negativos del carbono debemos
descarbonizar toda la economía
encontrando alternativas para el uso del
petróleo en todas sus aplicaciones ahora
en costa rica tenemos una circunstancia
particular nosotros somos buenos en la
producción de electricidad limpia y
somos líderes mundiales en ese tema por
eso en costa rica nuestra meta es en
realidad la electrificación de la
economía es decir llevar la electricidad
y utilizarla para reemplazar al petróleo
en todas sus aplicaciones pero esto por
supuesto conlleva otros retos primero
tenemos que aumentar dramáticamente la
producción de energía renovable además
tenemos que lidiar con la
acciones como la intermitencia y otros
detalles que conllevan las fuentes
renovables que poseemos hoy en día por
otro lado también el uso directo de la
electricidad no es posible o no es la
mejor opción para todos los sectores de
la economía por ejemplo para sustituir
el búnker en las calderas de un hotel o
de una industria o en los hornos de una
fábrica de cemento o para reemplazar los
generadores eléctricos térmicos que en
las industrias e incluso a nivel
nacional generan electricidad en el
momento en que necesitemos para
satisfacer demandas inmediatas tenemos
que encontrar una forma de transformar
la electricidad renovable para poder
llevarla a todos los sectores de la
economía y poder almacenarla y de manera
que sea tan práctica transportable y
estable como el combustibles fósiles es
decir que sea tan buena como el petróleo
aquí es donde entra el tema en el que yo
estaba trabajando junto con un equipo
compañeros el hidrógeno el hidrógeno es
una forma de almacenar y transformar la
energía eléctrica renovable y ahora sí
llevarla a todos los sectores de la
economía
el hidrógeno es un elemento químico es
la sustancia más simple que existe y es
la sustancia más abundante del universo
pero aquí en la tierra no la encontramos
nunca en estado puro es decir no hay
minas de hidrógeno sino que siempre está
combinado con algo más está combinado
con los hidrocarburos en el petróleo y
sus derivados con los carbohidratos en
la materia orgánica y sobre todo en el
agua el hidrógeno se ha utilizado como
un insumo industrial por muchos años
ilustró tecnología es bastante madura la
gran mayoría del hidrógeno que se
utiliza en el mundo hoy en día proviene
del petróleo del gas natural y del
carbón y este es el que llamamos el
hidrógeno sucio y aquí en costa rica no
nos interesa porque quedaríamos en lo
mismo
afortunadamente existe otro proceso que
también es técnicamente maduro y
comercial que se conoce como la
electrólisis del agua y este produce el
llamado el hidrógeno verde porque sus
insumos son la electricidad que es 100%
renovable en costa rica y el agua la
sustancia más abundante del planeta el
hidrógeno se utiliza para almacenar la
electricidad renovable y una vez que lo
tenemos en forma de
no podemos quemar este hidrógeno para
usarlo como combustible en aplicaciones
que requieran calor por ejemplo
aplicaciones industriales o sustitución
incluso de gases para cocinar podemos
utilizarlo como un insumo industrial
para las industrias químicas se puede
producir fertilizante
una serie de productos químicos e
incluso fabricar otros combustibles
sintéticos a partir del hidrógeno y
podemos volver a transformarlo
nuevamente en electricidad utilizando un
equipo llamado celda de combustible y
con esa electricidad utilizarlo en todas
las aplicaciones que requieran la
electricidad para para utilizarse en
todo este ciclo únicamente se producen
residuos como el oxígeno cuando se
produce el hidrógeno a partir del agua y
el agua que se recupera totalmente
cuando aprovechamos la energía es decir
es un ciclo libre de emisiones no es un
ciclo carbono neutro sino que es un
ciclo carbono cero en el caso del sector
transporte que es el que más nos urge
descarbonizar en costa rica el hidrógeno
se utiliza en vehículos que son 100%
eléctricos porque los mueve un motor
eléctrico no hay motor de combustión
porque el hidrógeno no se quema sino que
el interior del vehículo se transforma
nuevamente en él
la cual impulsa el motor eléctrico y por
lo tanto el vehículo se mueve los
vehículos de hidrógeno se alimentan o se
recargan en estaciones de hidrógeno o
hidrogeneras o hidro lineras y en estas
sensaciones los automóviles eléctricos
de hidrógeno adquieren un rango de
aproximadamente 500 kilómetros en un
tiempo que ronda de los 3 a los 5
minutos los autobuses y camiones se
recarga en un tiempo de 15 a 20 minutos
estos vehículos eléctricos de hidrógeno
poseen el mismo rango la misma potencia
la misma flexibilidad en las rutas los
mismos tiempos de recarga que sus
contrapartes de combustibles fósiles que
usamos hoy en día es decir son
prácticamente similares en todos los
aspectos excepto en las emisiones de
carbono y es que en esto radica el
atractivo de las tecnologías del
hidrógeno para usarse en el transporte
el hidrógeno hoy en día es uno de los
mejores medios que conocemos para
almacenar grandes cantidades de
electricidad en poco espacio poco peso y
poco volumen aunado esto con los rápidos
tiempos de recarga la flexibilidad en
las rutas la potencia que se puede
extraer de una de estos equipos celdas
de combustible
el hidrógeno es óptimo para el nicho del
transporte en donde cosas como el tiempo
la potencia los rangos son importantes
es decir en aquellos segmentos en donde
los vehículos tienen una función
comercial o son vehículos de trabajo por
ejemplo autobuses de transporte público
sobre todo los que requieran rangos
medianos y largos camiones municipales
de trabajo como camiones de basura
vehículos que pierden de dinero si están
detenidos como los taxis o los
montacargas eléctricos furgones de
transporte de carga pesada en donde yo
quiero llevar el peso de mis mercancías
no el peso del sistema que mueve el
vehículo hay barcos aviones estos
vehículos pesados
y de carga si bien en costa rica no son
la mayoría producen la mitad de todas
las emisiones de dióxido de carbono del
sector transporte si vamos a
descarbonizar todo el transporte tenemos
que encontrar soluciones para todo tipo
de vehículos hoy en día existen modelos
comerciales no prototipos de todas estas
aplicaciones que necesitamos tenemos
autobuses trenes eléctricos de hidrógeno
montacargas eléctricos que de hecho son
de los vehículos más exitosos en este
nicho
celdas de combustible que van desde
cargadores de celular plantas de
respaldo para centros de datos e
industrias y también generadores a nivel
de megavatios para integrarse en la red
eléctrica
tenemos ferrys botes camiones furgones
todos son vehículos eléctricos que se
mueven con el hidrógeno renovable y son
vehículos cero emisiones y por supuesto
también existen los automóviles
a pesar de esto persisten muchos mitos
que se repiten en todos los países en
donde se trabaja con estos temas se dice
que el hidrógeno es muy peligroso que
tenemos que acordarnos del dirigible de
1937 que es muy ineficiente que todo
está inventado que para que una
tecnología nueva si ya tenemos otras que
los cálculos no salen en el cuaderno y
los críticos más optimistas los que
tratan este tema mejor nos dicen que el
hidrógeno es la energía del futuro y que
para siempre va a estar ahí en el futuro
yo no estoy de acuerdo las empresas que
están trabajando en estos temas llevan
décadas desarrollando la tecnología lo
sé porque trabajo en una de ellas el
hidrógeno está ocurriendo hoy en día el
reto para insertar el hidrógeno verde y
renovable en nuestras economías hoy en
día es lograr que la infraestructura que
se necesita para producir este hidrógeno
verde té verde sea viable y
financieramente aceptable en nuestras
economías es decirles un reto financiero
y comercial no técnico
para lograr que el hidrógeno pueda
entrar en nuestras economías y ayudarnos
en el proceso de descarbonización
tenemos que lograr que sea competitivo
con los combustibles fósiles no hay otra
forma para comenzar a entender por donde
se puede trabajar esto es importante
entender que un kilogramo de hidrógeno
porque el hidrógeno se vende por kilos
produce el rendimiento equivalente de 2
galones de combustible fósil en costa
rica esto anda en el orden de unos 78
dólares por esos 2 galones de
combustible ese es el precio meta para
el hidrógeno verde y renovable alrededor
de los 78 dólares por kilo de hidrógeno
la buena noticia es que en costa rica
hoy con los precios de la electricidad
que están vigentes el día de hoy y
aprovechando todos los subproductos del
proceso es posible generar
infraestructura de hidrógeno verde y
renovable que anda en el orden de estos
8 a 10 dólares por kilogramo en costa
rica hoy descarbonizado segmentos que
otras tecnologías ser omisiones no
pueden dar el mismo rendimiento
resta los otros equipos que son
necesarios para montar un proyecto por
ejemplo tengo que montar y comprar los
autobuses si es un proyecto transporte o
debo comprar las celdas de combustible
si este es un estoy generando energía
para una industria estos equipos están
con sus costos de creciendo fuertemente
al igual que ocurrió con las baterías y
con los paneles solares en los últimos
10 a 15 años y por la misma razón el
mercado chino mientras tanto podemos
utilizar distintos trucos financieros
plazos preferenciales tasas de crédito
impuestos al carbono es posible hacer
proyectos rentables y viables el dinero
no es el problema o al menos no es el
principal problema
hace 135 años a un par de ingenieros
criollos se les ocurrió la descabellada
idea de iluminar unas cuantas cuadras de
la ciudad de san josé como unos cuantos
bombillos para peores se les ocurrió
hacerlo con energía eléctrica renovable
que estaban produciendo en una pequeña
planta hidroeléctrica que no les habrán
dicho en ese momento que eso era
peligroso que era muy ineficiente que
era muy caro que para que se había
lámparas de aceite y lámparas de carbón
que la electricidad seguro era la
energía de un futuro muy lejano y veamos
dónde estamos el día de hoy generando
electricidad 100% limpia a nosotros nos
toca completar toda esa gran tarea costa
rica- hoy es uno de los pocos países del
mundo y el único en américa latina que
tiene una demostración de transporte
eléctrico verde con hidrógeno verde
cuando muy pocos países del mundo
siquiera lo están intentando
imaginémonos a dónde podríamos estar en
unos años dependiendo única y totalmente
de nuestra propia energía energía limpia
como decimos acá vemos pongámonos a
trabajar todavía nos quedan muchos retos
que demostrar clases
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]